I would like to talk to you about an
exciting opportunity
I just need 30 minutes of your time to
explain it but it has the potential to
transform your life I'm talking about
multi-level marketing companies or MLM
companies like Mary Kay
Rodan and fields a new skin and way and
Herbalife they sell different products
but generally MLMs have two main things
in common first you don't see them on
store shelves you buy them through
distributors like a friends family and
co-workers and secondly those
distributors are always looking for more
people to join them and they have a
pretty attractive message why Herbalife
because you get to be your own boss earn
extra money
work from home raise your own children
you can name your own hours make
part-time or full-time money paying the
bills share this video with 10 people
that you care about that you love that
you adore that you admire 20 people 30
people come on what are you waiting for
100 people share with everybody they
want what we have we got it
okay hold on I'm supposed to share that
with 10 people I love adore and admire
that's a tough ask let's see um there
are the judges on this season of Project
Runway that's three oh there's Tim Gunn
that's obviously four if you count Tim
Gunn twice that's five but I'm still
five short and I am out now and before
you brush this industry off you should
know collectively it did around thirty
six billion dollars in retail sales last
year in the u.s. you probably know
someone who is considering joining an
MLM or who already has and is posting
about it ten times a day on Facebook or
Instagram and if you do know someone
like that or have considered signing up
yourself this story is important because
let me explain how the system is
supposed to work
generally distributors have two main
ways to make money sell the product
itself whether it's a makeup vitamins or
health shakes and earn money on those
sales and and this is key recruit other
people into the company and get money
based on their sales and the sales of
people they recruit intern
just look at Vemma a few years ago a
hidden camera caught our then
distributor for that company walking a
prospective recruit through just how
easy it can be
let's say you send three friends after
then you and I would help my friend send
a bigger and get there Samantha okay
it's nine people there right nine figure
sign uglier me the soccer that they get
enjoyment kind of gets their money back
wait you kind of get your money back
that is reassuring us hearing a doctor
say he kind of knows where your appendix
is it's probably somewhere near the
spleen and if you are thinking well hold
on that business structure sounds
familiar
isn't that a pyramid scheme well there
was a journalist waiting outside to ask
the exact same question
it's not an illegal pyramid scheme it's
a direct selling never market is it
shaped like a pyramid the business rug
is shaped like a pyramid yes but you're
saying it's not an illegal pyramid it's
not in the illegal pyramid scheme oh I
get it
so it's not a pyramid it's just pyramid
shaped you know like a Dorito or an
angry bird or just a pile of
but let's put that pyramid question
aside for a moment because from the
outside these companies do have the
trappings of legitimacy many have high
profile celebrity endorses at vemma had
noted science experts Jenny McCarthy
AdvoCare has esteemed ball thrower Drew
Brees and an MLM called max
international had this guy after more
than a year of due diligence gene and I
joined max international as home-based
distributors and media spokespersons Oh
to be a fly on the wall while Gina and
Chuck were poring over the numbers
during that year long due diligence
session Gina with an adding machine
Chuck randomly kicking stuff it'll be
like watching Lennon and McCartney right
sergeant pepper still for many MLMs the
biggest celebrity is their founder who
can enjoy cult-like status just look at
JR Ridinger CEO of market America at
company conferences the guy makes quite
an entrance
[Music]
Oh
okay fourth string wedding chapel Elvis
calm the down and that's just his
walk-on once he gets going he puts on a
real show demonstrating how you can pump
money dramatizing the rat race by sweat
aliy running around in a giant wheel and
screaming at the gravestone of Joe
nobody who never fulfilled his true
potential Joe come on man
the dreams you told me about we can
actually do them now we don't have to
wait man it works and I'm doing it and I
want to help you do it because it's so
good Joe this is amazing we can we can
have vacations and sailboats and we can
have multiple homes and you can give
your wife the the jewelry that she
deserves then you're gonna be a hero
come on now let's do it get out don't
get out before it's too late get up holy
all I can say is thank goodness funerals
don't have a speak now or forever hold
your peace section because he would be
at every Cemetery delivering
motivational speeches she lived a good
life q your grandmother died a loser
come back to life Ethel you can still
have that yachts come back to life and
that the dangling of vast lifestyle
improvements is at the heart of the MLM
pitch their materials feature flashy
cars and luxury travel that you can
achieve and just watch a distributor
from youngevity walk you through a
future dream scenario in exquisite
detail in two years this is what's gonna
happen to you you are gonna you're gonna
drive to your work you're gonna walk
into your boss's office you're gonna sit
down and you're gonna quit your job
[Music]
you're gonna explain that that little
pyramid scheme thing that you almost got
terminated for last year you're now an
entrepreneur and you're gonna be doing
that full-time whoa whoa back up back up
did you just say pyramid scheme and
then almost got terminated and then
you're going to go out to the parking
lot you're gonna get into your silver
Mercedes that youngevity has paid for
and you're gonna drive home oh no way
actually first you're gonna drive to the
bank I'm sorry I hate to dwell on this
but you definitely said pyramid skating
back then but I'm sorry now we're
suddenly going to the bank and you're
gonna walk into the bank and you're
gonna deposit your coding bonus and the
lady's gonna say will that be checking
or savings and you're gonna say yeah I
don't really care I get these all the
time and then the lady's gonna say haha
that's fantastic but I actually need to
know which account is goes into
and you're going to say makes no
difference to me and she's going to take
but I can't deposit this unless you
specify which account it's policy and
you're going to say it's all gravy and
she's going to say how about checking
and you're going to say I'm loving it
and she's going to say do I need to get
security and you're going to say the
account ending in 842 for players now
youngevity told us that that woman's
claims are not authorized by the company
and are against youngevity policy which
forbids income claims although that
video was taken at one of their official
events and the woman Denise Chennault is
featured with her husband on the company
website with the words Denise and Tom
Chennault are youngevity oh come on
you don't let someone embody your
company if you don't agree with them if
Flo turned out to run a dogfighting ring
progressive would wipe her off their
website immediately and by the way you
know that's coming you can see it in her
eyes there are dead dogs dancing in
there but but you cannot deny the
picture that she paints is enticing who
doesn't want to tell their boss to go
themselves half my staff would do
it right now if they cook but MLMs hold
out the hope that if you work hard you
can take control of your life start your
own business and help your family but
how real is the opportunity well let's
take a look at just one of these
companies in depth Herbalife you saw its
pitch earlier it was the one that you
were supposed to send to 10:20 a hundred
people
it sells nutritional supplements like
shakes and vitamins and it's one of the
biggest MLMs
around with net sales of 4.5 billion
dollars last year it has a celebrities
who talk up its benefits from superstar
athletes like Cristiano Ronaldo - pretty
much the last person you're expecting to
see in this piece well first of all you
have a great product that makes all the
difference
we got sorry buddy you're a product -
the product well I am a product of the
product it has every combination of
things that I like it's a very good
product delivered by really good people
yes that is Madeline Albright
talking to Herbalife CEO claiming she's
a product of the product so forget
studying at Columbia and Johns Hopkins
if you want to be like the first female
Secretary of State
just chug a couple of vanilla adjacent
you two shakes a day and thank her in
the morning
oh and about those products in its early
days Herbalife was accused of
overstating their health benefits
claiming in the 80s that one product
helped to relieve everything from
venereal disease to tumors to bedwetting
and back then their founder Mark Hughes
was asked by a Senate subcommittee to
answer experts who'd called his diet
products into question and this was his
response I think if they're so expert in
weight loss why were they so fat
yesterday it seems to me and I'm not
trying to make any jokes but I do think
that they ought to use our product first
he seems great but but second why would
anyone in the 80s take Herbalife to lose
weight they had cocaine come to think of
it we also have cocaine the point is
cocaine is an effective weight-loss
option it's not where I thought I was
going with this but it is where we have
ended up now to be fair that was 30
years ago and a lot has changed at the
company since then although when ABC
News filmed some Herbalife distributors
just two years ago they found some
claims that seemed to echo the company's
past this Herbalife distributor in New
York City told us the story of a woman
who overcame an inoperable brain tumor
thanks to Herbalife
a lot new recruits were told
Herbalife products help to treat heart
disease four years ago I had nothing
work even helped one woman get pregnant
my friend well that is obviously
nutritional shakes cannot help
you get pregnant there are only three
liquids that can do that a glass of
merlot the honey smooth music of Sharda
and good old-fashioned Jews and people
people might be making claims like that
because they are desperate to move
excess product you think broadly
speaking under Herbalife system
distributors can get bonuses and massive
discounts on products based on how much
they buy which can be a huge incentive
to buy in bulk
for instance let's say you're selling
Herbalife's disgusting creamy chicken
soup powder for 3035 blocks the cheaper
you can buy it from Herbalife the more
profit you could make but to stay
qualified for those higher discounts you
have to keep buying product and it might
not be easy to sell that extra soup
because a it's a little pricey and B we
actually tried it and it tastes like the
wood shavings inside a gerbil cage and
as one former top distributor will tell
you if you are just accumulating product
that can lead to a problem common enough
to have a special name we'd call it
garage qualified they would stack as
much product as they can in their garage
and at some point they would realize
that they have to quit so people buy
product more than they can then they can
sell it sits in a garage what happens
there's got to be an end point here at
some point when they run out of money
there's an end point exactly
so other life may be an industry leader
in worthless crap people stick in their
garage along with of course the PT
Cruiser the car that looks like a sporty
version of a hearse and and as a
distributor it is not easy to figure out
exactly how you are going to make money
just watch this Herbalife video from a
few years ago explaining one narrow part
of their insanely
convoluted compensation plan okay here
we go take a look at this example
now when e places a four thousand volume
point order at 42% this counts as
personal volume for you but since this
qualifies e to supervisor with a
one-month qualification that volume now
becomes encumbered for everyone in the
up line remember each up line
distributor needs to accumulate 1000
unencumbered volume points if they want
to qualify for supervisor as well
it's simple and if you accumulate 10,000
unencumbered volume points those are
grouped into an unencumbered batch which
qualifies benedict cumberbatch for one
unencumbered cucumber cummerbund and
well yes that is absolute nonsense
it makes exactly as much sense as
everything that came before it in fact
to hear another former Herbalife
distributor tell it your main focus in
the business might be less on products
than on the people below you you don't
make money from selling products you
make a little not much not enough to pay
the bills that are racking up you make
money from signing people up of course
it's like that famous salesmanship motto
from Glengarry Glen Ross abst CE OS TOS
always be selling the concept or selling
to other sales people and at this point
that pyramid scheme question that we set
aside earlier has to be addressed
because in broad terms
if distributors earnings come primarily
from selling products to actual
customers outside of the company that is
probably a legitimate business but if
those earnings come primarily from
selling product to the distributors
you've recruited below you and their
sales of product to the distributors
they've recruited below them all within
the company that may be a pyramid scheme
and any business that is set up that way
has a big problem for a reason that and
I will warn you does involve math almost
all of these schemes tell you that you
can make money by just recruiting three
or four five let's say five then you let
the five do they're five that gives you
twenty
five what they don't show you is that
you could only do that 13 cycles and you
would exceed the population of the earth
it's true within 14 cycles you run out
of people and that is assuming that
everyone on earth wants to be a protein
shake distributor and I can think of at
least a few people who have better
things to do Alan Alda
for instance or Malala yousufzai or
Morten Harket lead singer of AHA the guy
is still swimming in take on me money he
doesn't need this and an Herbalife
CEO Michael Johnson has an interesting
way of deflecting that whole pyramid
scheme question I go back to any company
I started in Disney as a director then I
went to be executive vice president and
then president of the international
entity of the coming so I moved up six
or seven levels and at the top was
sitting beside the company Mike Eliezer
is that a pyramid is that any different
than what we're doing here yes it is
completely different Disney was a
corporate ladder those were all salaried
positions with benefits the company
wasn't banking on you personally filling
your garage with cases of unsold DVDs of
The Lion King - Simba's pride but but
johnson could have made a stronger non
pyramid case in that interview if you
could have just shown how much money
distributors get from selling product to
actual retail customers but conveniently
Herbalife didn't keep records of those
figures now unfortunately for them the
FTC recently finished a multi-year
investigation into the company and filed
a blistering complaint walking right up
to the line of outright calling it a
pyramid scheme they alleged Herbalife's
compensation program doesn't incentivize
retail sales but rather the recruiting
of additional participants who fuel the
enterprise by making wholesale purchases
of product which sounds like you know
how pyramid schemes work
and when people pointed this out the FTC
chair made an amazing statement each
other we're saying is that this company
had all the hallmarks of a pyramid
scheme isn't that right
our focus isn't on the label the word
appear
pyramid does not appear in our complaint
that is true they were not determined
not to have been a pyramid think about
what she just said they're not
determined not to be a pyramid how is
that not a huge warning sign if the FDA
announced we have not determined cotton
candy not to be clown pubes you would
never risk eating that ever again
now now who knows why the FTC stopped
short
perhaps it ensured Herbalife agreed to a
settlement in which they neither
admitted nor denied wrongdoing but did
pay two hundred million dollars and
agree to significant new changes but the
contents of this complaint are
mind-blowing the FTC claims that the
overwhelming majority of Herbalife
distributors who pursue the business
opportunity make little or no money and
a substantial percentage lose money in
fact the FTC even stated Herbalife is
going to have to start operating
legitimately which implies they hadn't
been up till then and yet amazingly
Michael Johnson characterized this as a
victory hey we've got great news we've
reached an agreement with the US Federal
Trade Commission that ensures that our
mission to improve people's lives will
continue to thrive I have to tell you
this is really good news and it comes at
a time when our business is growing
bigger and better than ever before oh
you didn't just even just polish that
turd he put it in a bottle and convinced
people that they could make a fortune
selling nutritional turds in their spare
time but look whether Herbalife is a
pyramid not a pyramid or not not a
pyramid it is true that Herbalife is
growing and a lot of that growth has
come from Latino communities where
Herbalife has been aggressively
expanding for years they even brought a
sponsorship on the hit telenovela La Fea
mass bear
it's very subtle to just see if you can
spot it Mira se llaman Herbalife esto
Toma ayudar a tener más energía de
ballet tambien frent Arturo's problemas
que tienes creamy never dad yo lo tomó
todo reviens
never tasted religiosity if that is
happening on the show I can't imagine
the real drama happening in the
commercials
mr. Geico lizard I want to say 15% on
car insurance but how can i when you are
sleeping with my wife
and the fact a large percentage of
Herbalife's business comes from Latinos
is a point of pride for Michael Johnson
we call it your Bligh family and we're
not ashamed of that we're very proud of
that the Latino the the blood if you
will them you know it's in this company
and it feels great oh I love the blood
of a Latino community I just want to
bathe in it I want to bathe in your
blood Latinos how's this sales pitch
going I feel like it's going way no but
to those supply that Latino blood it can
feel less than great as this community
meeting of those who feel burned by
Herbalife shows de negocio y Ageha per
day la cantidad de de inc we don't mil
dólares en Nueva MSO purdy de mil
dólares her husband continuously reminds
her about the $8,000 that she owes to
them el producto 7 C so C note Odysseas
trataba de vender Lopo lo que tu lo comp
Rastas una gran pierre de ella sabia que
yo no tenía su dinero y esta bien dou st
end on la mía
yo di condo es que paso latino ninguna
ganancia y dijo
tu tienes que me tera gente Abajo de T
para que tu puedes ver una ganancia le
dije sabes que dicen day to take evoke a
steady yo no voy a estar ferony DN mess
so yo perdieron area
deport me you know what now might be a
good time to point out when someone says
their blood is in me and it feels great
that is what a fan Peyer says and
friends of yours may say well that
that's just Herbalife my MLM is
different but there are echoes of what
you've seen across this industry for
instance Herbalife is far from the only
company that has made bold product
claims regarding health when I started
my body fat with 37.5 and now it's right
around 1617 the pain and the lethargy
that go along with fibromyalgia is gone
three days into the experience I was
feeling like 25 years younger when I
found out they had a pet formulation of
liquid bile that's when I knew I had
something very exclusive after putting
Rembrandt on liquid bile cell pet for
three months he started walking again
okay first of all obviously good boy
Rembrandt
one second are you sure he didn't just
summon the energy to walk because he was
desperate to get away from the
eyedropper of liquid nonsense you were
shoving in your pets mouths and just
like Herbalife MLMs can often have
Scientology like levels for you to
ascend through with USANA you may have
gone from sharer to believer to builder
to achiever and beyond and at Kyani you
pass through a series of ranks with the
names of gemstones as a one distributor
explained at a company conference I want
to talk about a millionaire mindset
because if you got involved in Kyani to
become a Jade you're selling yourself
short if you got involved in Kyani
become a diamond you're not thinking big
enough yet if you haven't already
visualized yourself at double black
diamonds
you need to kick yourself in the rear
now double black diamond is technically
a skiing term for particularly dangerous
slopes and I'm thinking maybe you
shouldn't choose a term that basically
says if you even try this you'll go
downhill fast and may end up in a king
ditch and the garage qualified issue is
not exclusive to Herbalife either it's
come up with multiple other MLM
including Mary Kay I start with my own
two eyes
the
our housing of the product meaning they
had basements full of it or closets full
of it or garages full of it
take a look at this inventory from a
consultant who is leaving the company
she agreed to show us boxes of product
she said she bought to keep her status
Wow
so it seems some distributors may have
been more customer than salesperson
that's why finding out Jamie Lee Curtis
was actually the one eating all the
Activia I eat a hundred and forty six
containers a day and I like a
machine gun and Mary Kay and Herbalife
will tell you that stockpiling is
uncommon and you can return unsold
products for a refund but you should
know those refunds can be partial or may
involve resigning the point is MLMs may
present themselves as a great
opportunity but your chance of success
is actually remote just look at the
income disclosure statements kyani's
shows that just under forty percent of
active distributors received a check for
ten dollars or more meaning that most
didn't even make that and new skins says
around 18 percent of active distributors
earned commission checks which is
actually worse than it sounds because
active distributors represent only
around 36 percent of total distributors
so if you do the math which they
conveniently didn't that would mean that
93 percent of all new skin distributors
receive zero commissions from the
company in an average month so even if
you have never heard of Nu Skin before
it may be paying you just as much as it
does 93 percent of all its distributors
now MLM is winning
six those percentages are misleading
they will tell you that many of their
distributors aren't even in the business
to make money they just went to all that
trouble of signing up to get discounts
on their amazing Rhino ejaculate or as
they call it soup felt they'll del say
individual distributors like that Vemma
guy and those are herbal life reps don't
speak for them and that their claims are
against company policies and violators
get disciplined and most importantly
they will all insist they are not
pyramids and no one claims that any more
spectacular manner than JR Ridinger who
has an airtight case based on spelling
the word pyramid backwards we're
actually the anti pyramid the reverse
pyramid the dimmer ripe we are in a Dem
array he sounds like a cult leader about
to demand his followers drink poison and
it frankly doesn't help that he looks
like Jim Jones to a genuinely creepy
degree but it is hard for the FTC to
investigate these companies the industry
is large and opaque and pursuing a case
is a long arduous process
they've only brought around two dozen
pyramid scheme cases against MLMs in the
last four decades and MLMs have
surprising lobbying strength there's
actually a direct selling caucus in
Congress with more than forty by parties
and members including jason Chaffetz who
worked at Nu Skin for more than a decade
as for Herbalife it has gone to
remarkable lengths to protect its name
in Washington its recruited two former
top FTC officials to work for the
company and it's willing to be
incredibly petty as well because
remember that clip of Herbalife victims
that is from an upcoming documentary
called betting on zero and when it
played at a DC Film Festival earlier
this year the screening had one hundred
and seventy three empty seats because an
Herbalife lobbying firm reportedly
bought them out and that's not just
petty it's stupid if you don't want
people to see a movie you don't need to
buy out seats just put up posters saying
starring Shia LaBeouf
job done nobody's there but even if the
government did suddenly decide to crack
down on this industry which seems
unlikely many MLMs have been expanding
overseas here is a video from India via
changing people's lay you are the brand
we are growing every day let's master
worth 1 million 1 billion one region
[Music]
come to
they are lucky Gandhi isn't alive to
hear that song because it would really
test his belief in nonviolent protests
you know what kid everybody pick up a
rock and meet me at herbalife
headquarters that song was unforgivable
just look online and you can find videos
of gigantic Herbalife events around the
world
here is one in South Africa here is one
in Mongolia here's one in Venezuela
here's one in Malaysia and here is
Michael Johnson in Mexico doing this Wow
I do not say this lightly but that is
douchebaggery at a double black diamond
level so the point is what can we do
because good hard-working people are
going to keep getting caught up in these
companies there has to be a way to tell
the world about the dangers of MLM and I
think I might know the perfect
distribution network but as this video
is for Spanish speakers and I do not
speak Spanish I need to hand over at
this point to hi make a meal
got it sharp dresser the skillet I got
it let's do it
I got the suit I got this okay
esta noche vamos a iniciar moestro
propios came a pyramid ad
hasta este es un esquema de pyramid
porque yo no se nada que estaba pensando
Munir c'est un sistema de mercado multi
nivel esta es una gran oportunidad de
canaima straddles cómo funciona
[Applause]
ah today como el mercado mucho el es lo
peor de lo que o para explicar Nez Nahor
al compartir es tu steady se pueden
convertir Anan distribuidora
Independiente de un video sobre los
peligros del mercado multi Nibin esto lo
pueden hacer a tiempo completo o partial
y le van Adara su familia el estilo de
vida que realmente cemre SN KS custom
Entei no verse am well toes en esta
mierda necesitan una prueba scientific
adel tsukushi onami ento muy bien le
dijimos son pero que vamos a to z de
este video y Miren loca curio l pero
esta caminando por dia caminar antes lo
siento pero no word on moses registros
ashes cómo funciona simple men save en
este vídeo que despues ren VL o a cinco
personas Iligan days que lo r ND n a
Cinco mas y que el siglo so repite una y
otra vez después de catorce AC clothes
cada be taunted este planet Elora visto
yaga ramos al punto en el que vamos a
tener que ver como locos para recoger el
planeta para ver lo tambien si esto yaga
a cada v taunted el planeta
citas Yendo Yonsei soy un gran fan
dis etl amigos que hablan Ingles que
crayon Jaidev amber Algy Rio también
tenemos una razón en ingles no esta su
tip you la de ya segment' ov a Sarah -
ah dope or Juan Oliver cuando la
definitivamente see una version mucho
más attractive aditi n todos los
aspectos see
hace que por favor Vartan este vídeo
para poner teen a que la gente se VNV
Welton en estos desk Emma's porque el
mercado ultimen el Ultima Ville esta
effect and hola gente y necesitamos
correr la voz de sus Pulido's hace que
por favor MVNO intente trente OC n
personas t esperamos el sistema de
funcionario in us una eldunari es una an
Teairra Mari esto es una pyramid assert
o siento esta es una pyramid
[Applause]
what
you